good morning Hank it's Tuesday first
things first Hank you are a dad
Katherine had a baby boy over the
weekend his name is Oren he is adorable
and I am so so happy my excitement about
this baby is at the level of lake cheese
doodles guys yeah yeah this also means
that hank is really and truly on
paternity leave now but fear not in the
coming weeks we will have several
excellent guests Hanks beginning this
Friday with nerdy and quirky Sabrina the
second things second next month will be
the 10th annual project for awesome wait
is that possibly correct oh my god I'm
old I'm super old when did I become old
it was this weekend when my baby brother
had a baby I've gone from cheese doodles
guy excited to glimpsing the void in
less than a minute but right the 10th
annual project for awesome no need to
fear how old you've become we'll begin
at noon Eastern Time on December 9th and
we need your help in a couple ways first
though some background the project for
awesome started in 2007 when
nerdfighteria essentially tricked
YouTube's algorithm into featuring
videos about charity over the years the
project for awesome has evolved a lot
but it's always been focused on one
decreasing the overall level of suck in
the world and to encouraging people to
make great videos about their favorite
charities so here's how it's going to
work this year first hopefully many of
you will make project for awesome videos
the idea here is that on December 9th
you upload a video about a charity you
care about you explain why the work they
do is so important and how they do it
well and then you encourage people to
vote for your video at project for
awesome calm this is a great way to
spread the word about your favorite
charities and also the charities that
receive the most votes will get grants
last year the top voted charities
receive $25,000 apiece then there is the
live show so for 48 hours straight
beginning at noon Eastern Time on
December 9th there will be a continuous
live stream here at the vlogbrothers
channel hosted by Hank and me and lots
of special guests in the live stream
we'll be highlighting our favorite
project for awesome videos probably
covering our faces in peanut butter and
also raising money for charity
there will be an IndieGoGo with lots of
great perks from all kinds of amazing
youtubers and all the proceeds will go
to nerdfighteria charity the foundation
to decrease worldsuck
which I know doesn't sound like a real
charity but I promise it is one it is a
federally sanctioned 501c3 organization
and yes your
nations are tax deductible if you live
in the United States and possibly if you
don't but I don't know your tax laws
right okay so the foundation to decrease
worldsuck has no overhead because
everyone who works for it volunteers
their time which means that 100% of
donations less the cost of producing and
shipping physical perks goes to charity
over the last three years we've raised
more than three million dollars how do
we choose the charities well during the
first half of the project for awesome we
raise money for pre selected charities
this year they will be saved the
children and Partners in Health these
are both great organizations our
community has worked with for a long
time and we've seen the impact that our
donations to partners in health and Save
the Children can have from Bangladesh to
Haiti to Ethiopia to the United States
to refugee camps in Jordan pre-selecting
charities also allows us to gather
matching donations which means that for
the first half the project for awesome
every dollar you donate will be worth at
least two dollars which reminds me if
you happen to be a person who wants to
make a very large donation to this
year's project for awesome say anything
over a thousand dollars please email me
at Hank and John at gmail.com with the
subject line matching we will add your
donations to the matching fund and Thank
You profusely and to reiterate your
donations are tax-deductible
okay so then during the second half of
the project for awesome will raise money
for charities chosen by you the
nerdfighter community by a voting at
projectforawesome.com last year the
winning charities ranged from water org
to the American Association for suicide
prevention it's up to you to decide what
charities to make videos about and which
to support with your votes here's what
we could use from you right now in
comments one perk ideas what perks would
get you excited about donating to this
year's project for awesome or what perks
have you loved in the past and number to
guest suggestions are there people you
would love to see on the project for
awesome live stream if so let us know in
comments Hank
congratulations congratulations
congratulations I will not see you on
Friday but it's okay I will see Sabrina
and you have a baby